child tuck yourself in bed and let me
tell a story of Lemuria a long lost
kingdom in a girl born for gly it's hard
to ignore just how beautiful child of
light is for the first few minutes of
the game I just SAT there gawking at the
gorgeous watercolor like landscapes
oblivious to the fact that there were in
fact some neat ideas Droon amongst the
pretty visuals it is after all a
marriage of two disparate genres the 2d
platformer and the turn-based RPG
however child of light simplifies and
condenses as many classic RPG mechanics
to fit it shorter running time and make
things a little more accessible HP MP
skill trees weapon upgrades buffs spells
and turn-based battles are all there but
a far less complex than a new average
RPG in the few hours i played the game
I'd already worked my way up to nearly
level 20 and a lot quite a few blocks on
my characters skill tree still I found
child of Lights rewards came not from an
endless array of menu options but from
the combat itself their battles relied
less on candy equipment choices and more
on death timing essentially was all
about the balance between executing a
Defense Command and launching an attack
by way of a bar that showed when the
characters including enemies were
waiting to attack and when they were
actively casting if I launched an attack
while an enemy was casting one of theirs
he would interrupt it and send them to
the back of the weight bar the reverse
was true too so if I attack just as the
enemy was getting to the end of a
casting period I'd have my attack
nullified simple enough but it got quite
tactical as I timed my defense moves to
the rhythm of the opposition's attacks
and began using slow to ensure my
attacks were perfectly timed or the
enemy used haste to speed up their time
to casting it was a fun tactical system
although once I got to grips with it the
battles themselves weren't particularly
challenging the potential is certainly
there for it to come into its own during
more difficult encounters and I've got
high hopes for it doing so later in the
game even if it doesn't though child of
Lights aesthetic qualities go a long way
towards picking up the slack
a captivating soundtrack accompanies
beautiful visuals while a cast of cheeky
fireflies melancholy jesters and grumpy
gnomes and their rhyming dialogue of
utterly charming that's not to mention
the puzzle filled platforming elements
of the game and the fairy wings my
character was gifted with that let me
gracefully flutter through the dreamy
watercolor landscapes child of light is
a game that's filled with charm and
joyfulness no matter how much I pondered
about it having a deeper set of RPG
mechanics or battles with the more
challenging sets of opponents I couldn't
help but be utterly smitten by it and if
that happened after just a few hours
lord knows what a mushy mess I'll be
when I get my hands on the finished game
can't wait the Queen has earnest and
with her the light dark resided in its
place the server Umbra did from sight
she sent her daughter's in her stead the
Sun the Stars in the crescent moon they
pilfered from the sky extinguished them
with the monsoon the numbers dark
creatures conquered the land our lives
soon snuffed out by a wave of her hand